all right
phil mickelson yesterday winning the pga
championship at the age of
50 the oldest golfer to win a major i
still don't really regard the pga
championship as a major oh what he did a
fourth one i feel like they needed a i'm
sorry it's the ringo star of golf majors
in my view well ringo was damn good he's
one of the greatest drummers ever so you
need to readjust your damn thinking okay
but they got they got the masters yeah
at the u.s open they got the open
in britain which we call the british
open and then they needed a fourth one
so yeah okay pga championship there you
go there's your fourth one there's your
there's your there's your fourth mast uh
your fourth uh major anyway yeah i'm
kidding i know we uh we got you did you
watch it all yesterday did you did you
check it out at all no not really i
could already tell by your face look
there no
no no no although everyone that i follow
on twitter was watching it and actively
tweeting about it so i didn't need to
watch it i knew exactly what was going
on phil mickelson won i watched none of
it sorry for that uh but
thank you for that phil because today's
draft the most impressive old man feats
in nfl history uh chris trivia question
who is the oldest player to score a
touchdown in nfl history oldest player
oldest player to score a touchdown hold
on i'm just trying to think
i
i i mean it's it's gotta be bland or
brady i'm gonna go with brady i'm gonna
go brady
yeah there you go it was okay you got
extra time to think that one through and
i'm really surprised you needed as much
time well i just wanted to make sure i
became a kicker i know i just wasn't
sure maybe they had you know i don't
know i just wanted to think it out for a
second all right go ahead you got the
first pick go ahead what do you got well
it's almost like
i mean
really do we do we want to do this i
mean brady that's my first old man feat
brady the last five years
i mean that's really it's amazing okay
we'll just go brady from last year i
don't give a damn i know i'm looking i
mean brady was that's special what he
did last year i don't know what else to
say the damn guy's throwing laser beams
around the field still he's 47 years old
he's 43 i know but still it's everything
he's done the last few years he's the
first to break down all these barriers
as far as this deep into the 40s this
consistently good
doesn't really get banged up or hurt i
mean it's just it's pretty damn amazing
so i don't want to pick this because
it's the obvious thing here but i mean
brady just everything he's done here
just in the in the recent past is is
absolutely phenomenal and mind-blowing
as matt casey points out and i say that
so i don't get the blame for it he does
forget the down from time to time as we
saw last night yeah that's right well in
case he's a jets fan he's looking for
any way to kick
on brady
but you know you
you initially said the last five years
for brady yeah and my thought is i
should just pick the next five years
seriously right this year this year will
be the great feat because it's not going
anywhere and i think he is going to play
more than two more seasons two more
years would put him at the expiration
date that he has abided by for a long
time he used to say 10 more years 10
more years then it became 45. i don't
know i think he's going to play beyond
that jason light has left the door open
for him to play until he's 50 and based
on how he played last year maybe he can
i'm going to start with
uh peyton manning yeah setting the
single season passing yardage record at
an old 37. yeah not a young tom brady 37
that was a rickety old 37 for peyton
manning i mean just two seasons later he
barely held his body together for the
finish line of the season and and i
think that makes what he did in 2013
setting the single season passing
yardage record even more impressive how
close he was to everything falling apart
to have
that kind of production is amazing yeah
it was amazing amazing like
i mean you're right he didn't do it with
like just unbelievable physical ability
a course could still throw and timing
and rhythm and all those type of things
but just like always got them in the
perfect play it was always like a scheme
screw over you're like oh my gosh he
audible to this and this guy's wide open
it's the easiest touchdown you've ever
seen and i mean he could have thrown for
65 touchdowns that year that's really
what you got to remember how many games
did he come out with five six eight
minutes left in the fourth quarter
because they blew people out because
they scored points at such a at such a
fast pace so i'm with you that was a
good one by you uh i wasn't sure if you
were going to go there i think i got to
go jerry rice next i mean just be like
you know it it to me it's every bit as
impressive or equivalent to tom brady
because of the position you're playing
like 1200 yards at the age of 40
and go to a super bowl
and you're still the main target for the
best offense in football and rich gannon
who's the nfl mvp and you score a
touchdown in the super bowl and all that
like come on that's insane we don't we
don't got anybody that's threatening to
be that good at the age of 37 8 9 or 40
in the nfl right now so jerry rice is
the tom brady of wide receivers and in a
lot of ways that that's it's in a lot of
ways it's maybe even more impressive the
fact that you know at 40 you still got
to run he's still got to run 4-4 or 4-5
and be sharp cuts and take hits over the
middle and all that so that's amazing to
me
yeah you know we we talk about concerns
with julio jones at age thirty two and a
half thirty three jerry rice had
eighteen hundred and forty eight
receiving cards that's number
it was a record at the time yeah in 1995
and it stood until calvin johnson in
2012.
i am going to go next with and i've got
a bunch here i got to go with daryl
green
playing 16 games starting four of them
at corner in 2002 at the age of 42 of
all the positions on the field
right to make it into your 40s at corner
and still be able to run with receivers
and cover receivers at corner at age 42.
the guy was drafted in 1983 at corner
and he was still playing 20 seasons
later that to me is amazing insane
insane i mean you know you see here
we're picking it's it's freaks of nature
that old man feeds just like phil
mickelson yesterday the guy he's 50
years old he had the longest drive the
whole tournament on on hold 18. like
those are freaks of nature that's that's
what you're seeing daryl green is
unbelievable i grew up watching him i
used to be scared to death of them and i
would hope he'd trip and fall every time
he was playing the giant so because i
mean he was such a special my dad has
stories about daryl green mike where
they used to run like you know the old
double move slant and go right and he
was so fast that he'd bite on the slant
but he could recover so quickly that
he'd cover the go part like so they
invented the triple move where it would
be slant go and then run the comeback or
an hour out off of it because he was so
good at recovering and things like that
they had to add another element to it um
but so that's a good pick by you and i
forgot about that that that's pretty
amazing um
all right whoo
i'm not sure which one i want to go with
here uh
i'm gonna go i do want to go with florio
getting out of bed every morning but i
won't do that quite yet it's not an nfl
history thing so funny
but i'll go with
um i think i'm gonna go john reagan's
john riggins
you know
coming back
out of football
right
plays two more years
led the nfl i believe in rushing two
straight seasons and of course had a
super bowl mvp to go along with that to
beat the miami dolphins and that killer
b defense and everything like that so
again it's not going to be as impressive
looking right now but in the early 80s
when you're in your you know 33 years
old and you were a power running back
that was quite the damn feat and diesel
they cranked up that diesel
and he was really good remember that
from nfl films when they do that
yes
uh all right we're we're getting short
on time let me just run through a couple
that i have on my list curtis martin led
the league in rushing at age 31
1697 yards of career high at age 31.
chris dolman 15 sacks in 1998 at age 36.
ben roethlisberger 501 yards passing at
age 38 a rickety 38 for him that was
impressive but i got to go with the guy
who turned 94 last week we played the
video i think on friday in honor of
thursday
in his late 80s bud grant one of the
all-time great coaches and still going
strong uh that it was six below he
doesn't even flinch it doesn't you
couldn't tell by his reaction it could
be 86 he doesn't look like he's
uncomfortable at all he's like oh
screw you cold weather i'm gonna flip
this coin and show you what it's all
about i mean yeah that's that's pretty
amazing who else did you have his mind
oh sorry and i i've read them off yeah
and i you weren't you're paying
attention it was all mental and that's
when when the vikings played in the cold
like that no jackets no heaters no
anything it's all mental and they had
that edge and it made a difference and
now they play endorsements yeah i know i
uh i had sorry i know i did listen to
you i don't know why i asked you but um
brett favre
you know his run there at the end of his
career that was pretty damn good hey
elway come on let's not he was the
oldest starting quarterback to ever win
a playoff game and he won the last he
won his last two super bowls and walked
off into the sunset as a super bowl mvp
now that i'm saying that out loud that
is stupid i didn't pick that one part of
the draft yeah
let's take a break hey old timer we'll
be back soon ragtime music plays us out
to play us out what does it mean to play
us up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports